( intro music )
Mike Libecki: Sixty five
expeditions and counting
and the goal is to
do 100 expeditions
by 100-years old.
This is what I call
the Polar Bear Fang.
And I've been trying to
this tower for ten years.
For a climber this is
as good as it gets
as far as unclimbed,
untouched.
This was a unique trip
because I had planned to go solo
and my younger brother said,
"Hey, I'd love to
go on this trip."
And I was like, "We're going
to do this huge climb".
He's not a climber but he
was gonna go along anyways
and see what happened.
And I thought, "Okay,
I can just teach you what to do.
You can follow me up this climb.
We'll go on the belief of
blood and brothers and
we'll communicate and
it'll work out."
There's polar bears here.
The easiest way to be safe is
to sleep up high on a ledge.
You can see our
base camp down below.
Immediately the next day,
after getting dropped off,
made a beautiful base camp,
packed up our bags
and started shuttling loads.
That's the first view
that we got
of the Polar Bear Fang
from camp,
because there were some
big cliffs in front of us.
And so, at this point,
we're getting up there
and we're starting to
have to cross glaciers.
I'm teaching my brother
how to tie into a rope.
And, you know, how do you tie a
figure-eight knot again and...
This is our high-camp,
From that high-camp,
we still got about
half a mile to the
base of the wall.
We went, we slept at
the base of the wall
and we started climbing.
It got really serious because
my brother is not a climber.
And so, he's on ascenders,
he's on Jumars
following me up the rope.
and a lot of times we had fun
but lot of times I'm like
"Listen, you gotta do
this, this and this."
And, when I am leading pitches
I'm putting directionals in for
the rope to run a certain way
so he doesn't pull off a
rock and kill himself.
And, you know, it was,
it was the real deal up there
and we put the cameras away.
And I'm like,
"We've got to focus on safety."
There were three different
times I had to switch routes
because it was just too
loose and dangerous.
There were two times where I
talked to him about it and said,
"We might have to bail,
it might be too dangerous."
And, honestly, my mom
she would kill me
if something happened to the
baby brother, to the youngest.
( audience laughter )
It was pretty exciting to stand
on top of the Polar Bear Fang
after a decade of
wanting to be up there.
( mimicking horns clashing )
Mike: Yeah, Year of the Ram!
Woo!
First ascent here in Greenland.
Ah, now we got to figure
out how to get down.
( audience laughter )
Time is now, life is sweet,
talk to you soon.
( Mike chuckles )
He was a good sport to wear the
Year of the Ram mask, and...
But the summit is pretty
powerful, I mean,
there is an incredible feeling
about standing on a summit
in a fjord,
an area that's unexplored,
a climb that's--
You know, a new climb,
a first ascent, it's,
it's really a powerful feeling.
And to share it
with my brother...
We're very close,
we always have been,
it was such a magical moment to
be up there with him.
And it was just incredible.